one of the defining aspects of your
approach to Amazon is just being
obsessed with making customers happy I
think uh companies sometimes say that
but Amazon is really obsessed with that
I think there's something really
profound to that which is seeing the
World Through The Eyes of the customer
like the customer experience the human
being that's using the product that's uh
enjoying the product they like what
their like the subtle little
things um that make up their experience
like how do you optimize
those this is another um really good and
kind of deep question because there are
big things that are really important to
manage and then there are small things
in internally to Amazon we call them
paper
cuts so we have we're always working on
the big things like if you ask me and
and most of the energy goes into the big
things as it should so um and you can
identify the big things and I would
encourage anybody if any you knowbody
listening to this is a
entrepreneur as a small business
whatever um you know think about the
things that are not going to change over
10 years and those are probably the big
things so like I know at in our retail
business at Amazon 10 years from now
customers are still going to want low
prices I know they're still going to
want fast delivery and I just know
they're still going to want big
selection so it's impossible to imagine
a scenario where 10 years from now I say
where customer says I love Amazon I just
wish the prices were a little higher or
I love Amazon I just wish you delivered
a little more slowly so when you
identify the big things you can tell
they're worth putting energy into
because they're stable in time okay but
you're asking about something a little
different which is in every customer
experience there are those big things
and by the way it's astonishly hard to
focus even on just the big things so
even though they're obvious they're
really hard to focus on but in addition
to that there are all these little tiny
customer experience
deficiencies and we call those paper
cuts and we make long lists of them and
then we have dedicated
teams that go fix paper cuts because the
teams working on the big issues
never get to the paper
cuts they never work their way down the
list to get to they're working on big
things as they should and as you want
them to um and so you need special teams
who are charged with fixing paper cuts
where would you put on the on the paper
cut Spectrum the buy now with one click
button which is I think pretty genius so
to me like
okay my interaction with things I love
on the internet there's things I do a
lot I maybe representing a regular human
uh I would love for those things to be
frictionless for example uh booking
airline
tickets just saying but you know
it's buying a a thing with one click
making that experience frictionless
intuitive all aspects of that like that
that just fundamentally makes my life
better not just in terms of of
efficiency in terms of some kind of
cognitive load yeah cognitive load and
peace inner peace and happiness first of
all buying
stuff uh isn't a pleasant experience H
have having enough money to buy a thing
and then buying it is a pleasant
experience and like having pain around
that is somehow just you're ruining a be
a beautiful experience and I guess all
I'm saying as a as a person who loves
good ideas is that a paper cut a
solution paper cut yes so it's probably
that particular thing is probably a
solution to a number of paper cuts so if
you go back and look at our order
Pipeline and how people shopped on
Amazon before we invented oneclick
shopping there were a whole Ser there
was more friction there was a whole
series of paper cuts and that uh
invention eliminated a bunch of paper
cuts and I think you're absolutely right
by the way that there when you come up
with something like one click shopping
again this is like so ingrained in
people now I'm impressed that you even
notice it I mean most every time I click
the
button surge of Happiness this there is
in in the perfect invention for the
perfect moment in the perfect context
there is real Beauty yeah it is actual
Beauty and it feels good it's emotional
it's emotional for the inventor it's
it's emotional for the team that builds
it it's emotional for the customer it's
a big deal and you can feel those things
but do you keep coming up with that idea
with those kinds of ideas I guess is the
the day one thinking effort yeah and you
need you need a big group of people who
Fu that kind of uh satisfaction with
creating that kind of
beauty